you argue a lot yeah but I mean it's not
I don't want to paint the wrong picture
I mean but the stupidest arguments we
had one the other day which this is true
this is this is this is how it went down
she's not a dog person and I we have
three dogs right
and so there's Me Mine and the kids and
whatever and she's no and the Bulldog
she's got a thing with the Bulldog she
wants him keep him out of the living
room so she puts the fence or up keeps
him out of the living room okay he got
in the living room he made a mess
diarrhea I don't even like to say I
don't like to say it right but it's a
new set and I think we can do it right
yeah yeah that's what this new format is
for what had happened that's when they
say the show's looser
[Laughter]
hey feels good doesn't it an applause
break for the guy on the right yeah
exactly
but anyway so she's mad she's mad and
and and then she comes at me and she
goes and you know what he doesn't on
purpose he doesn't I'm purpose and I'm
like no I'm like I'm trying to
rationalize with her he doesn't and then
finally I give in I go alright maybe
because you keep him out of there maybe
he doesn't perfect and she was I swear
to god this was [ __ ] she was no no no no
he makes it diarrhea on purpose yes like
and I'm like what do you think he has
like a setting on him
I swear and she's an intelligent woman i
but she's sticking by it she's like no
he's and I'm like I can't and I can't
get her to go back on it and finally
just rationalize with this okay let's
say he does let's say he can let's say
somehow he can decide the consistency
whatever it is how does he know that
that one's harder to clean up how does
he have that awareness yeah yeah very
good very good
yes but no she's feast expired yeah
that's what that's the kind of arguments
you have after 30 years